الى جانبي توجهها القومي وبعضها ليسري
تشجع هذه الفصائل والاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه القيم النسويه في صفوفها وغالبا
ما تقدم نفسها على انها احزاب اجتماعيه
ديمقراطيه على راس هذه الاحزاب ياتي الحزب
الديمقراطي لكردستاني فرع ايران وهو اقدم
حزب كردي ايراني ويؤكد انه يكافح من اجل
تجسيد حقوق الاكراد القوميه في اطار ايران
فيدراليه واديمقراطيه اما عن واقع انتشار
قواعده الشعبيه في الداخل الايراني فتتركز
على كردستان ايران حيث مدن مهابات
وماريان وكاميران وسردش وهناك احزاب املاء
او حزب كومالا الكردستاني ذات توجه يسري
قومي لطال منادى بانشاء دوله كردستان
ايران ويمتلك معسكرات ومقار عسكريه في
اقليم كردستان
بعد 100 كيلو متر من الحدود مع اراده
وتتركز قاعدته الشعبيه في الداخل الايراني
بالمناطق الكرديه لاسيما في مهاباد وسقز
وسرداش واوريميا واطرافها ومن بين الفصائل
الاخرى التي استهدفت خلال الاشهر الاخيره
بالقذف الايراني حزب الحريه الكردستانيه
الذي يضم مقاتلين شاركوا في معارك ضد داعش
في كردستان العراق وينتشر بقوه في مناطق
الام وسنه ومهباد ومروان وكارمنشاه وسقف
وارميه وسارداش في الداخل الايراني وهناك
ايضا الحزب الديمقراطيه الكردستاني في
كردستاني ايران لزعامه خالد عزيزه ويعتبر
الحزب منشق عن الحزب الاساسيه وهو
الديمقراطي الكردستاني ايران وهو الاخر
ايضا يمتلك قاعده شعبيه كبيره في الداخل
لاسيا في ماريوان ومهابات
[موسيقى]
يا احمد